[Musique]
qui sont tous ces inconnus que nous
croisons dans la rue est ce que le cas
échéant ils peuvent nous aider nous
rendre service ou tout simplement nous
tendre la main
nous allons essayer dans ce reportage
pris sur le vif de les provoquer premier
tableau seul sur un banc apparemment
ennuyé que puis-je espérer des autres
[Applaudissements]
moi je regarde
pourquoi avez vous demandé si j'avais
besoin de quelque chose que je trouve
bizarre cheese and us à la saison 10
secondes tout le monde regarde demandait
ce que vous avez et si j'avais bien
quelque chose qu est ce que vous auriez
pu faire ma première manche je vous
avais invité à boire infosys
si vous aurait accepté mon goût en
aurait discuté de ce problème et vous
avez le temps vous avez du temps à
perdre avec moi la wii puisque je ne
fais rien petit après midi justement que
même si j'avais pas tant je vais quand
même consacré un petit peu de temps pour
vous j'ai pas je dois avoir une personne
seule la vitesse ça vous arrive jamais
de voir quelqu'un qui a l'air ennuyé
ah si ça m'arrivait je demande six jours
et on vous rend bas parfois parfois dans
le pot méchamment je comprends les
jambes
cet enfant de deux ans est seul dans la
rue les passants bien souvent ne le
remarque n'aime pas parfois cependant
ils sont étonnés mais n'interviennent
papote
rassurez vous il ne risque rien car nous
sommes cachés nous veillons sur lui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous sommes allés dans plusieurs
endroits et c'est partout la même
indifférence
[Applaudissements]
et cette dame qui va le prendre par la
main et véritablement une exception
[Applaudissements]
troisième tableau la valise une très
très très grosse valise très très lourde
à porter et beaucoup de gens très très
très indifférent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le français très tôt
franchement merci êtes gentil
je vais loi merci
[Applaudissements]
tu es au métro la main en avant c'est
passé vite attendait ces gentilles mais
dès que vous êtes pressé oui nous aurons
des chemins millions la salle intime et
des mercis quatrième table où le malaise
cet homme n'est pas bien il s'effondre
sur le trottoir
monsieur
je suis pas vu
ça va pas du tout
à
[Applaudissements]
pas
à
[Applaudissements]
ben ali
merci il est 3 heures de l'après-midi
sur les chances d'élise et une foule
très dense déambulent au sol à effet cet
endroit que nous avons choisie pour
simuler une agression
laissez moi tranquille son prix
laissez-moi conquis lâchez-moi
[Rires]
qualifiant écoutent oui mais les bus
qu'ils avaient des papiers montré des
papiers monsieur
même en ces papiers ci est créé au
secours prouver que c'est votre femme
j'aimerais vraiment monsieur rené lâche
pas monsieur se vante ma vie si vous
allez retrouver la mère se moquera
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]